meet Brian Stone in 2005 he was just a
regular guy walking around the clock at
part-time jobs in restaurants and
factories but he was barely making ends
meets he was killing himself to make
money and didn't know how much longer he
could take it and that's when a friend
told him about an opportunity to make
some easy money that would change his
life forever a clinical trial all he
would have to do is take some
painkillers and drink alcohol during a
four week study so doctors could observe
the effects and they would pay him 2 500
for the pleasure his friend insisted
that it was basically like getting paid
to party at first Brian thought it was
too good to be true but when he looked
into it more he realized that yes this
clinical trial was the real thing and
they were offering thousands of dollars
to participants so he decided to give it
a try what was the worst that could
happen so Brian signed up only to
quickly realize that clinical trials
were a lot different from partying this
experimental painkiller drug made Brian
violently ill throughout the entire
study the clinic staff told participants
to use a bucket rather than the toilet
if possible so they can look through
them I meant to see how much of the pill
had been digested before it came back up
he said it got so bad that Bryant ended
up forcing himself to throw up his daily
dose because he didn't want to feel the
intense side effects anymore it was pure
hell
but at the end of the study he was
indeed headed that 2 500 check and just
like that Brian was hooked not hooked on
the painkiller drug but hooked on
clinical trials because not long after
like he's done it for another clinical
trial this time to test a diabetes drug
Brian soon became friends with other
clinical trial participants and started
regularly looking up more studies he
could join he quit his part-time jobs
and even moved to a different city that
had more clinical trials available for
Brian clinical trials became his
full-time career he was officially a
professional guinea pig and on one hand
Brian was indeed helping save many lives
but on the other he was taking
experimental drugs as a full-time career
and it sounds extreme putting your body
on a line to be one of the first humans
to try a new drug or medical treatment
but it's actually a huge business well
it can be a risky Endeavor but it can
pay big dividends perfectly healthy
people signing up for a battery of
medical tests CBS 2's Lisa Siegel shows
us how they're cashing in on clinical
trials today there are thousands of
professional guinea pigs out there
making a living by participating in
clinical studies years before any
medication hits Pharmacy shelves drug
makers have to prove it's safe and
effective that requires guinea pigs one
man named Paul Clough runs a website
where people can find new trials that
are available in their area Paul himself
has been in more than 80 drug tests in
the past 11 years as a full-time job and
he makes a good living with it too these
clinical trials fund his everyday
expenses and even provide him enough
money to take a trip to Alaska to
photograph the Bears most of these
clinical trials pay around 250 a day but
some studies can pay as much as fifteen
thousand eighteen thousand or even
twenty nine thousand dollars for a lot
of people this is life-changing money
and when big Pharma booming in America
the business of clinical trials is also
booming the only question is when you
went out your body like this and what is
it really like to participate in these
clinical trials and what are the dark
sides that no one talks about
stay dangerous and welcome to the world
of professional guinea pigs
[Music]
foreign
drug can affect the whole population
like something out of a sci-fi movie
that's why almost every single drug wink
wink goes through a rigorous testing
process before being approved for public
use these clinical trials have been a
thing for over 275 years but the first
one being conducted by a ship surgeon
who is trying to learn how to treat
scurvy and we've been using clinical
trials ever since and it's a very big
business it costs an average of 1.8
billion dollars for a Pharma company to
develop One Drug from scratch just one
drug with a clinical trial alone taking
10 to 15 years or more but the payoff is
worth it because if they can bring a new
drug to markets they're going to make an
average of 18.6 billion dollars from it
so the question becomes would you trade
2 billion dollars to make 19 billion
that is the incentive of these farmer
companies both the giant big Pharma
companies we all know and for a ton of
small biotech companies are hoping to
strike it big getting just one new drug
through clinical trials is the dream for
small biotech companies because they're
going to be going from zero to
potentially billions upon billions of
dollars sometimes you study are funded
by the government private investors
Charities universities or other research
institutions but usually it's the Pharma
companies that fork the bill since
they're the ones that are going to own
the race to the drug and if you want to
bring a drug to markets here is Hell
phase one of a clinical study is testing
for safety the very first step in the
process is to figure out if the drug is
safe to use at all and if so what is the
safest way to use it and the first study
in humans is about getting to understand
how the body deals with the medicine
phase one is the riskiest part of the
process and the least regulated it's
also the phase where the majority of
professional guinea pigs work and where
they make the most money because after
all more risk more reward phase two is
when you evaluate Effectiveness next you
need to know if the drug even works by
trying to treat an actual condition with
it and if it works you can move on to
phase three determine value you have a
drug that is safe and works against a
condition now you gotta see if it works
better than the current treatment for
that condition if the answer is yes
congrats you can submit your drug to the
FDA for approval leaving you with a one
more phase phase four watch overtime
when a drug passes all these tests it
can be made available to the public but
there is still one last phase long-term
side effects phase 4 is about seeing how
people react to the drug after using it
for a long time and learning about the
drug side effects this is arguably one
of the most important parts of bringing
a drug to markets because as we all know
with the opioid epidemic there can be a
lot of unforeseen long-term effects of a
drug and that is why companies are
willing to pay people so much cash to be
in the clinical trial because to them
it's nothing a few thousand dollars for
someone to try our drug that could
potentially make us billions it is a
no-brainer and so for those that are
brave enough they're able to make a
pretty comfortable full-time income
depending on how you define comfortable
oh foreign
the life of a professional guinea pig
can be tempting for the right person
think about it all you have to do is sit
around receive some sort of medical
treatment you don't need any skills any
hard labor any prerequisites and boom
you're making a full-time income you're
even given a fairly comfortable place to
stay and decent food to eat and it even
comes with a free physical examination
but perhaps most importantly as Dale
Carnegie once said everybody wants to
feel importance and participating in a
potentially life-saving trial will
definitely give the participants a sense
of importance and here's how you can do
it yourself if you so choose first off
you want to find a study where you fit
the criteria for and then you go through
an intense screening process you'll be
interviewed over the phone to divulge
every detail of your health history then
they'll have you come in to take your
vitals blood and other samples to figure
out if you're telling the truth and
finally if you get through all that
you'll be invited to the study and
that's when things get real
yes when you come in you'll be searched
we look through their bags we look
through their pockets and you remove
your shoes this isn't the
isn't the jail just a little bit error
on your part can take the paint the
entire trial so these guys are very
serious about making sure all the
participants follow the rules to
participate these drug testers have to
be perfectly healthy and you lose your
freedom to do what you want they eat
only the meals served by the scientists
every morsel is measured and calculated
if you drink or eat something that I
don't eat it affects how the medications
absorb everybody has to do the same
thing you'll go through a bunch of
standard medical procedures before
finally receiving whatever treatment
you're testing for a friend of a friend
told me it was a quick way to pick up
some cash blood draws heart testing diet
plans and mystery drifts they're all
part of life inside a clinical trial
yeah later on which can range from basic
cold medicine to psychedelic drugs like
psilocybin but you could also be
receiving a placebo like a sugar pill or
something and still get paid and even
with all the strict rules there are
still a lot of benefits you literally
get to sit around watch Netflix play
games eat sleep well hopefully not
violate vomiting or having explosive
diarrhea no more boss yelling at you you
don't even have to worry about what
you're gonna eat for dinner I would
personally never do this unless I was
deathly ill but to each their own and
right now you can find so many paid
clinical trials to participate in there
are over 437 000 registered clinical
trials in 2022 which is more than triple
the amount there was even a decade ago
so the opportunity is there but there's
just one really important thing to
remember when you take a new drug into
humans for the first time it's never
without risk the whole point of clinical
trouts is to make sure a drug is safe
and sometimes
unsafe at all
[Music]
March 2006 location Norfolk Park
Hospital in London phase one clinical
trial for tgn 1412 antibody therapy
organized by parric cell compensation 2
000 pounds participants eight healthy
men aged 19 to 24. researchers were
optimistic about
tgn1412 it was supposed to treat things
like leukemia and autoimmune diseases by
boosting the body's immune system they
believed they had something
revolutionary on their hands and after
injecting the drug into monkeys without
problems it was time for The Next Step
trying it out on human test subjects
medical personnel gathered their eight
chosen participants into hospital rooms
and hooked them up to IV drips before
slowly starting to inject them with the
experimental drug and within just a few
minutes everyone realized that something
was horribly wrong the patient's whole
bodies went freezing cold they started
complaining about immense pain in their
heads and backs I felt my head swelling
up like an elephant's one participant
remembered I thought my eyeballs were
going to pop out everyone was panicking
the test subjects and the medical staff
and it only got worse from there they
tumbled like dominoes
[Music]
hold on
I remember being sick into one of those
big yellow biohazard bags
oh it was terrible I must have brought
up a good leader of bile just solid bile
oh my God
it was all manic
everything was happening all at once
they were vomiting
they were screaming in pain people
fainting one participant even tried to
escape fighting against a medical
personnel to reach the exits for some
reason patient three started to think he
would do better if he got out of this
place
was saying things like I don't want the
money anymore I just want to get out
he's just started panicking started
freaking out it's really important that
you stay in the bed but he was begging
he just when he was saying he wanted to
go home he was screaming in pain and
which was the most kind of harrowing
kind of moment the patients were moved
into an intensive care units and they
tried desperately to keep them calm
hoping that the drug will wear off and
things will get better but that is not
what happened how close I was to dying
it's hard to say it's not something I
went out of my way to to find out it's
not something I wanted to know things
got so bad that medical staff started
calling their participants families to
have them come to the hospital in case
it was the last chance they had
it was about 3 30 a.m and my phone rang
it was one of the nurses and she said
that there had been an issue with the
drug trial and I needed to get down to
the hospital as soon as I could
it was really shocking news my heart
kind of raced and I had no idea what was
really happening and what she saw when
she arrived at the hospital was horrific
I don't think anything could prepare you
for what you see when you first go in
okay
foreign
his cheeks were very swollen so much so
that his eyes were they look more like
slits
his face was just round like a ball
and his stomach was huge I thought he
had had his hands on his stomach because
there was that large
until I realized that his hands were
actually beside him on the bed
it was pretty scary to see somebody
you love
suddenly be so disfigured from what you
remember them
some of the patients spent weeks trying
to recover on the brink of a very
painful death and even after they
recovered they weren't sure if they
would ever be okay again my organs were
back working but I was like an 80 year
old my muscles were just wasted away
what was in the drug or the storm it
created it's supposed to like Attack yo
um cells such as bad cells like cancer
and things like that but because we
didn't have anything like that it
started attacking our own tissue our own
muscle and it just wasted I definitely
remember thinking that although they say
where we could be okay within three
years there was the concern that we
wouldn't because who knows what's going
to happen there's the chance that all of
us end up with the same illnesses and
then what happens others ended up this
figure to this day
I saw that his fingers had blackened and
there was no hope for saving those
fingers I realized that he was certainly
in a worse condition and he'd come off
of this in a very bad way it was
horrific on its best day working as a
professional guinea pig is an easy way
to make more money but on his worst day
human guinea pigs can be the subject of
a science experiment gone terribly wrong
so is it worth it
[Music]
on one hand clinical trials give people
the chance to make money without much
efforts but when you think about it
clinical trials typically Target a very
specific type of person one who doesn't
have many other options homeless people
fell and struggling parents broke
students some companies even travel to
low-income countries to find
participants who are more desperate to
be in the trial and earn some money big
Pharma companies know that these types
of people need cash more than anything
else and they're willing to put their
bodies on the line to get it meet the
kids I have two sons that I just want to
see the best of and I like to put money
towards anything I can for them so
Stephen and all these other trial
participants told us they'd do it again
in a heartbeat but on the other end of
the spectrum clinical trials are also
perfect for people who are sick that
badly need help so why shouldn't they be
allowed to take the risk why shouldn't
they be paid for the time in fact there
is an argument to be said that clinical
trials are too restrictive FDA
Regulators have an incentive to be
restricted I'm an FDA bureaucrat and I
approve something that hurts somebody
I'm in real trouble and there are
lawsuits I might get fired but if I
delay a drug even for years thousand
people die nobody knows who that person
is I don't get in trouble for that
that's why the FDA always tries to make
sure that it never lets an unsafe drug
on the market even if the cost is years
of delay many many lies lost what's the
solution have no FDA yes says Canon some
people would try drugs and the drugs
would kill them yes some people would
have adverse drug events but the number
of lies that we would save would
absolutely swamp the number of lives
that we lose to unsafe drugs the entire
premise of an agency like the FDA is
that you're not smart enough to make
these decisions for yourself it is a
tonic an Elixir to purge the body and
lift the spirits but maybe we're not
smart enough before regulation lots of
people were hurt by quackery I'm not
smart enough to judge whether the pill
really works or I'm being sold snake oil
and that's why the FDA exists it's not
true you're not smart enough to make
this decision yourself John because you
can consult experts you can consult your
physician you can consult medical
journals you can consult Consumer
Reports you can consult government
regulatory agencies in other countries
every day the FDA delays costs lives the
FDA needs to get out of the way let
these patients make that decision for
themselves as of right now someone's got
to participate in these clinical trials
and if it wasn't for clinical trials we
would not have a lot of the medical
knowledge we have today
take cancer for example growing up most
of us are taught to believe that cancer
is just this random thing that just
happens or that it's genetic so you
really can't do anything to prevent it
when in reality only five to ten percent
of cancers are genetic the rest is
lifestyle and environments which means
90 to 95 of cancers are preventable if
all you did was improve your lifestyle
avoid things like plastic fake food and
not be obese you will not need any fancy
Cancer Treatments but it's not the same
story for our parents for a lot of our
parents they didn't know any of this a
lot of them are pretty hard-headed too
so the damage to them has already been
done and there is a good chance they're
gonna get cancer so we still gotta come
up with better treatments for them that
are less extreme than chemo and one
company that is doing that is called MX
biofarm the paid sponsor of this video
full disclosure and disclaimers linked
below one of the cancers MX is working
on training is multiple myeloma a type
of cancer where your Healthy plasma
cells that normally help you fight off
infections turn cancerous and mx's
treatment for it is a Cell Therapy
called nxc201 and guess what NFC 201
just passed clinical trials and is now
FDA approved which is insane news as you
know clinical trials take years and on
average less than eight percent of them
are successful and mx's NXT 201 happen
to be part of that rare eight percent MX
is a public company listed on the stock
markets so if you believe in what
they're doing and you want to learn more
about this news that just broke you can
check them out by scrolling down and
clicking the link below once again Amex
is the paid sponsor of this video full
disclosure and disclaimers link below
but that is not all MX is also hoping to
replace traditional treatments for
cancer-like chemo with something called
tissue specific Therapeutics which lets
you target cancer cells of the same
tissue without affecting other tissues
and their IMX 110 therapy is already in
Phase 2 clinical trials so not only do
they have one treatment that just got
approved but they have many more in the
pipeline and now that you're well versed
in clinical trials you know that Phase 2
means that the treatment has gone
through the riskiest part of the process
it's been tested for initial safety in
the past and this clinical trial is
being done on patients with cancer with
an advanced tumor that have a life
expectancy of at least three months so
these people are really in need for a
solution and guess what just last month
they announced that three out of four
patients experienced tumor shrinkage
after two months the tumors got smaller
and one out of four patients experienced
tumor control after two months which is
huge this treatment was granted the
fda's orphan drug designation and the
fda's rare pediatric disease designation
and if you're curious there have been
zero drug related serious Adverse Events
or saes so really promising stuff if
these clinical trials are successful you
already know how massive this could be
for MX and for the cancer patients that
will have another options besides chemo
so scroll down and click the link below
to check out mxnow
thank you
[Music]